скандалу з панамським та документами вже
майже два місяці устілки зараз вона
макаєте розслідувати в шорті new bar
качею українців високо пасодобль і
прийду 7 президента Петра Порошенка та
фігуру і у панамських по бенкетах створ немає
їм годин і злічу комісії для
розслідувань всього скандал про таке
блоку волосся
адже в темно їх ще за і створ не такі
проголосуйте ось і чим робота комісії
можеш but i'm all ефективну та не
матами політико-правових на зливки
поважають експерти всі папороть годинника
якщо чеку міс вважаєш чималих
однак конкретному результату
у крем політичних заявка піаром
головна причина шлюб повного жінкою
вони таких комісій парадоксу чи
українці та зараз вона загадковості таки
наук волин закон проти годинника якщо чеку
місії a-jays four і не може стати
засіки першинг роком до імпічменту
всього і боялася руси президента України
сторони по шлюбу там про національне
антикорупційне бюро повз і повне ж
не будуть його прямування ще до глави
держави президентський манить ця можна
зняти алеша верховна рада бути їм
видно процедура тест чітко не
прописано цю роботу тим годин якщо чиїх
комісій